to face unafraid the plans that we
maintain walking in a winter wonderland
it was the week before the massacre
finale and we were gifted with not one
not two but three eliminations in a
two-night Holiday Spectacular I'm
Charlie O'Keefe and of Deidre Behar yeah
unfortunately we said sayonara to the
thingamajig and the leopard but before
we get into that we got to pay our
respects to the Christmas tree who was
chopped down in last night's episode
hate to say it we're golden call that
yeah you know we're such big fans of on
a gas tire and she is an actress who I
want to see more of in 2020 I think this
was a perfect show for her it really
showcased that she's not just the funny
girl that were used to seeing like of
course in the Soup Nazi episode on
Seinfeld or on SNL she's really like a
multi-hyphenate and she is such a talent
and I think the show was so perfect for
her
did you enjoy her I thought it was
ironic she went home on a Christmas
episode well she's out talking about her
Christmas album that just came out right
now sugar she's out there right now and
in my favorite recurring event Here I am
pulling the receipts on yet another
celebrity who was caught in denying
their own involvement in the masked
singer only to be unmasked later on the
mass singer and a blatant lie
take a look if you might think it's me
I'm not saying it is me I'll tell you a
great way to find out and that's to buy
my album sugar and boost alright let's
get back to the latest eliminations
everyone's favorite free Green Monster
no not the Grinch the thingamajig
again I just can't get enough of these
like really feel-good stories on the
mask singer Victor Oladipo what a guy
he's had such a tough year which he
alluded to several times on the show of
course the biggest obstacle being his
knee injury which set him back but in a
way it kind of opened the opportunity
for him to be on the show and we got so
much good music out of him how are you
doing I'm sad but I'm also happy maybe
nicole has a date now we don't know it
could happen we can go anywhere anytime
anyplace the other thing that I think is
really cool about the thingamajig was
how much he talked about family
throughout this whole process of course
hey sister who is hearing impaired and
then he mentioned his parents who came
to this country with nothing both of his
parents are immigrants his mom from
Nigeria his dad from Sierra Leone and I
think this is the American Dream seeing
your son not be an NBA star but also a
singing star both at once different
types of stars but we support both of
them yes and I thought the gift clue
that they brought out was really a big
one that gave it away it looked like a
Indiana Jones style hat and whip well he
plays on the Indiana Pacers but I bumped
got him
but the thingamajig wasn't the only
performer that was revealed we also said
goodbye to the leopard everyone please
ascend deidre your condolences how are
you feeling right she's not okay well
take a look
[Applause]
are you composure are you to be okay no
I'm probably gonna be unwell for at
least the next 12 or so hours
anybody who has watched this after-show
knows I Stan Steel this guy has got a
heart of gold so much talent I loved
watching him compete on this show this
is a guy who really has so much fun and
you can see it with how he did this
entire process and the fact that he
really did it for his kids really just
sort of won me over and put me even more
over it yet I'm calling them his Cubs I
thought it was so adorable and I think
tonight after he did it his kids are
definitely gonna be proud what a cool
thing to do what coolest thing in the
coolest way to end the year in my
opinion of course in the clew package
tonight for the leopard the Brahms
Lullaby music sheet of course seal
recorded a version of that song in
German he is that talented he can sing
in different languages the other thing I
noticed was the CD that said cancelled
so I had two theories on this one number
one in 2001 fans were awaiting the
arrival of possibly a new album called
together land and it got cancelled so it
could have referred to that the other
meaning the second meaning could
possibly mean that he felt like part of
canceled culture after all I know trust
me anything but seal please do not
cancel seal after all the drama with his
divorce and Heidi Klum played out and he
felt kind of like kicked down and and
knocked over by the media and fans and
whatnot so I don't know lots of multiple
meanings at the end of the day I am very
upset that the leopard did not win but I
am thrilled that he had such a
victorious run on the show and also we
saw it in his gift clue he has a two
year diploma in architecture because I
found it extremely talent I mean this
man literally does it all you can build
a home sing go on the mass sing or dance
everything we're not worthy I love you
seal Charlie I don't know about you but
the only thing I'm asking for this
Christmas is a recording of the foxes
festive performance tonight
[Music]
listen I know daytime television it's
what I care about most and I know Fran
Drescher how to show and someone made an
appearance why don't you find out
Wayne Brady who we have suspected has
been the Fox all along actually
performed this exact same song on the
short-lived but highly amazing Fran
Drescher show take a listen sang the
exact same song and sounds the exact
same I kind of love that though
absolutely you cope he has a good cover
of that song also we saw in the clue
package a lot of bowing I think you've
mentioned this before as well Wayne's
done Broadway this isn't something
strange to see him do he can definitely
not nod to his Broadway resume bowing
all the time in a suit package also we
saw palm trees in the background at one
point no I didn't notice it's the first
time but I ready to wash it again he was
born in Georgia but grew up in Orlando
Florida
Wow makes sense to me huge indicator
right there my other big kind of red
flag that was like this is Wayne Brady
in case we haven't said that enough on
this show was the gift that he brought
out at the end of his hormons it was a
picture of the rabbit from last season
of the masked singer of course the
rabbit was Joey Fatone now Wayne Brady
and Joey Fatone are very close friends
lots of pictures of them together in
fact earlier this year Wayne was a guest
on Joey's podcast up next the Rottweiler
certainly took us to the bright side
with his killer performance
I love this guy I know you'd end I love
this cover of mr. Brightside it was
different it was great and he has some
vocals and I've said it once and I will
keep saying it well we think this is
Chris Daughtry we're still sticking with
our guns on that one I actually googled
is Chris Daughtry a killers fan and he
mentioned that in a Rolling Stone
article many many years ago so we have
that going for him there the other big
thing that I noticed was a Christmas
gift that was addressed to cadence at
first I was like who is that maybe his
wife's name or one of his kids names
it's actually the name of his band when
he was in high school
Cadis I need not say more no literally
nothing else but I did wonder one thing
let us know in the comments below he we
saw a passport in the clue package I
could not find anything of what that
could relate to did you pick up on
anything unclear on the passport I know
that the man travels the globe
singing in and entertain me enough the
other big thing that I that I noticed
was the presence of a comic book yes and
we've talked about this actually before
on this show Chris is such a gifted
artist and you follow him on Instagram
you see all the drawings and renderings
of beautiful superhero or comic book
themed things which actually was the
gift that he brought out on stage a
custom drawing for the judges so the way
something about those pink fluffy
feathers that take me to church every
single time get ready to feel goosebumps
here's the Flamingo
[Music]
I did I love that song it's one of my
favorite songs of all time and that
cover is one I be playing on YouTube
over and over again a completely on
repeat if you love we think this is
Adrienne by law and Houghton if you love
her and you love that cover chances are
you're a fan also of her husband Israel
Houghton who is an incredible religious
Christian artist the two of them have
collaborated several times but there's
one song that I think fans really really
love take a listen
[Music]
and speaking of Israel what else did you
find in that clue package well the gift
clue was a globe with Israel pinned I
mean that is a large statement they're
making it pretty easy for us here's some
smaller statements I did pick up on
though we saw pancakes she is a big
advocate for a recipe a vegan apple pie
pancakes she posts about it all the
times on her website on her YouTube I
love it I need to try them make them
home also we saw an applause sign the
real is a studio audience TV show that
would not her current career in TV I
love that all the applause for you
flamenco so we bid adieu to Ana Gasteyer
Victor Oladipo anyone named wonder seal
which means we are officially down to
the final top three masked singers yes
we are next week the flamingos the
Rottweiler and the Fox will battle it
out to see who will take the ultimate
golden mask trophy let's make a bet who
do you got I'm going with my current
favorite the Rottweiler how about you
well you know I was rooting for the
leopard but I also really really really
loved my girl the Flamingo and what team
are you guys on let us know in the
comments below and join us next week
we'll be live to recap all the finale
five yes we will be live I can't wait on
that Deidre Behar and I'm at Charles E
O'Keefe it's manali time
[Music]